in the U.S the Democratic senator Rafael
Warnock has defeated his Republican
Challenger Herschel Walker in Georgia's
runoff contest for a seat in the Senate
this was the final race to be decided in
this year's midterm elections warnock's
win gives the Democrats an outright
majority in the Senate without needing a
tie-breaking vote from the Vice
President in an emotional victory speech
the Southern Baptist preacher thanked
Georgians God and his family Warnock
will serve six years as a senator until
2028
and the wsus correspondent Sumi
sumascanda has been following the runoff
in Georgia and here's her assessment of
its implications for U.S politics
in the end this was another important
victory for President Joe Biden and the
Democrats this is the first time since
1934 that the party in the White House
did not lose a single senate seat in the
midterm election so it's certainly
something we'll see the president say is
a proof that his party has performed
well and is performing well for the
American people now when it comes to
concrete results this is also important
for President Biden because it means
that he can get his judges confirmed the
president has the power to nominate
judges the Senate alone confirms those
judges and now with an outright majority
in the Senate that means that those
nominations will essentially get the
green light it's also important for
committees it means that the Democrats
have a majority in the Committees in the
Senate those committees have an
important role to play in shaping
legislation going forward as well and
last but not least for the Democrats
this is a sign that Georgia is territory
where they can be competitive they have
invested so many resources and so much
money in making sure that they can be
competitive in the state particularly in
the metropolitan certain areas like
where I am in Atlanta now for the
Republicans they will be asking
themselves some tough questions after
this runoff race Herschel Walker not the
strongest candidate that they could put
forward but also he was a candidate
hand-picked by the former president
Donald Trump many republican officials
now asking themselves the question what
influence should the former president
have on this party going forward
particularly knowing that he will be
running for the presidential office
again coming up in 2024 so it's back to
the drawing board for republicans and
certainly a Victory lap for Democrats
and the President Joe Biden